let's say it's the early 15th century
and you're a young citizen of a northern
German city of Rostov playing the new
online game right shadow legends you
begin this 3d online RPG by choosing a
starter hero to fight your battles with
and Dan Lang can get many more heroes
from the summoning portal to build up a
full team with this ragtag group you can
then complete quests challenges and
progress through the campaign the
graphics and animations of this game are
great looking smooth 'less the art style
has this delightful feeling of a sort of
cartoonish reality and you can get this
charmingly looking game right now on iOS
Android and PC with cross-platform
support that means you can play with
your friends no matter what potato
they're playing on so what are you
waiting for as part of the new player
program there's a special in the
description that will give you a 50k
silver to start off with and a free epic
champion to put into that ragtag team
you plan to conquer the world with good
luck and thank you for a chat origins
for sponsoring this video
Rostock is a very rich autonomous
Hanseatic city within the duchy of
Mecklenburg and is a valuable
shipbuilding port for the Hansa outside
of it off stock the Hanseatic League as
many members with its headquarters in
lubic it operates a very wide trade
network across numerous northern
European cities some cities are members
of the league just like you no stock
orders just have permanent
representatives of the league living in
their City ensuring streamlined flow of
trade goods and some cities which are
very important to the Hanseatic League
but are an autonomous and are under the
domain of a foreign monarch meaning the
cities can't join the league fully have
what the Hansa calls a contour which is
an independent part of a city with extra
privileges granted by the local ruler
that allows them to live under their own
Chairman rules local rulers were usually
strong-armed by the league to give these
extra privileges to the contours because
honza was a very powerful and rich
entertain medieval northern Europe and
they rarely took no for an answer
plus they always brought a lot of trade
to an area which was always a plus for
any local monarch however going back to
Rostock recently the dukes of
mecklenburg have been trying to crib the
city's autonomy and bringing more into
the fault of their influence which is a
very similar situation that many other
Hanseatic cities have found themselves
under recently nonetheless you don't
care for grand politics that seem to
move very slowly taking decades to
resolve some time
plus the Hanseatic League seems to be at
the height of its power it's not like
from now on it's going to gradually
shrink it to the exertion of more direct
control by local rulers and being pushed
out by national globalized trade
companies that do business across
multiple continents um of edgy don't
even know exist yet that's not gonna
happen you're living here and now in
Rostock looking to make money looking
for a job and there's no better paying
employer in the city than the Hanseatic
League a medieval European trading gilt
of which your city is a proud member of
and from which the Hanseatic League
recruits young boys from young boys oh
yes I forgot to mention you're most
likely 12 but that's fine it's the
middle ages so this is nothing unusual
with the offer of a home a stable income
and education and the possibility to see
the world you don't hesitate to sign up
now usually young boys are recruited by
the Hansa because one of their family
members mostly their dad is already a
merchant in the league however this is
not always the case so for the sake of
argument let's say your parents died of
the plague and one of your very close
family friends was a Hanseatic merchant
who helped you get signed up
now honza didn't only recruit 12 year
olds you could have technically signed
up at any point in your life but the
older you were the less likely you were
to get in with that said many young
adults usually through family
connections or their own influence often
easily got into the league but I digress
before hands accepts you you have to
fulfill certain criteria are you male
check do you speak low German check are
you low German check have you lived in
the Rostock for more than seven years
check are you willing to remain
unmarried / unattached for a certain
amount of time usually 7 to 10 years you
might think this is a ridiculous
question since you're 12 but you're
actually legally allowed to marry since
12 and most of medieval Europe even
though this was very rarely practiced by
females who usually married between 14
and 20 and almost never practiced by
males who usually get married in their
early 20s but it did happen sometimes so
sure what the hell check are you young
healthy strong basically well-suited for
harsh manual labor check can you be
trusted with leeks trade secrets well if
your YouTube comments are anything to go
by then no but I'll give it to you
anyways check these aren't the only
criteria and there were many more
criterias which changed
depending on what city you're being
recruited from what period of the
Hanseatic League you're being recruited
in or just the literal preferences of
the person who's doing the particular
recruitment nonetheless you pass all
these criteria and are awarded the title
of Steuben younger office boy or office
helper and the league decides you'll be
sent to live for seven to ten years in
one of its most northern contours in
Bergen you promptly leave roughstock on
one of the league's merchant ships
wondering if you'll ever see the city
again but are nonetheless excited for
what lies ahead the reason why the
Hanseatic League even operated in Bergen
are multiple the largest reason being
the cod trade cod which is so numerous
in the North Sea unlike the herring of
the Baltic Sea which has I relied upon
before expanding its trade northward is
a much less oily fish meaning after
being wind right unlike the herring it
can last for years before going rotten
and the longer you can keep your trade
to get liquid the better plus on top of
being a fairly large city with plenty of
access to the local North Sea fisheries
willing to sell their product Bergen at
this time also had a sizable German
population these Germans were mostly
artisans like cobblers tailors etc that
came to Bergen due to the lack of
well-made homegrown Norwegian goods
these two aspects and multiple other
ones meant that Bergen was the perfect
city in Norway for the Hansa to set up
shop and so they did you arrive in
Bergen and the ship drops you off on the
north side of the harbour the first
thing you see are a large colorful
wooden building surrounded by Palisades
guarded by dogs and seemingly separate
from the rest of the city what you see
is the Bergen contour known as Bergen
the isolated nature of the bryggen from
the rest of Bergen is on purpose the
Hanseatic League wants you to focus on
your work and nothing but the work
everything else is a distraction and
even though this is the official
standing of the league it is rarely
fully enforced the Bergen citizens often
participate in brigands social
celebrations brigand merchants often
have clothes Berg and Friends and the
contour even operates a public wine
cellar for the locals nonetheless your
show that each Calvo house is called the
yard which is where the members of the
league live conduct business have social
gatherings etc each yard is also divided
depending on the geographical area
where the merchants come from so all
merchants from Westphalia live in one
yard while all merchants from Lower
Saxony live in another yard etc
naturally since you're from Rostock
you're put into the yard where all
merchants from Mecklenburg and Pomerania
live every yard has a Council comprised
of all the senior merchants living in it
the council elects a house master in
charge of basically everything that
happens in the yard the contour as a
whole also has three elected alderman
responsible for the entire contour and
the communication with the league itself
and lastly the elder men are advised by
an elected council of eighteen deputies
each yard also has its own flag and some
amazing name like the unicorn the golden
shoe or my personal favorite the sisters
so you're a newcomer to the contour and
the first night of the sisters yard you
are promptly hazed which includes but
isn't limited to just simply getting
punched and kicked being pelted by
pieces of crap getting ice-cold water
poured on you and are being thrown into
the local well after surviving that
you're officially part of the sisters
yard and of the bergen contour and you
can start working your way up the
Hanseatic corporate ladder your official
work is a Steuben unit involves cleaning
the yards the bathrooms the ships and
also attending classes in the dining
hall here you are taught how to read and
write in German and sometimes Latin do
basic math bookkeeping and various
merchant laws and do's and don'ts of the
industry you live in one room with five
to seven other young members of the
contour and are not allowed to talk to
the senior members of the league unless
spoken to
nonetheless you do your work your
studies and get involved in the very
close and social community of the
contour three years have passed and you
have been upgraded to a boo team game
also there's no better way of putting it
you're a teenager now as a boots in gear
you no longer have to clean the contour
or the ships but are in charge of taking
care of the boats which includes
everything from maintaining the boats to
making sure the boats all ready whenever
needed and when they're not needed
making sure they are stored offshore so
they won't be stolen
you're further now required to be part
of the rowing crew for the boats as well
plus when the fishing season ends and no
agents from all over Norway come to
Bergen to sell their season's catch
you're awakened at 4 a.m. and are put to
work to haul all the new fish bought by
the hands
you do this until 9 p.m. with only two
short breaks for breakfast and lunch you
do this for a couple of weeks before
returning back to the normal Hanseatic
trade work also now that you're 15 or
maybe even when you were younger it's
very hard to gauge the average age of
sexual activity in the Middle Ages you
start to participate in an act that many
other guys from the contour participate
in as well and that is to sneak out at
night to the street that lies just north
of Bregan
this is because the street north of
bryggen is known as the Bergin's
red-light district and since the contour
is filled with young males all of whom
vowed not to get married or romantically
attached for their seven to ten years
stay at the hands at contour as one
historian puts it there was a large
overdose of testosterone that needed an
outlet to prevent violent clashes the
league officially surround upon these
practices because as they put it you
might tell the native woman under the
influence of her charm as well as that
of liquor thinks she had best not known
those being the Hanseatic trade secrets
but despite this in practice it was all
very much tolerated by the entire league
there was even in law found in one of
the books at the London contour which
states that if two or more merchants
were planning to bring women to the
confines of the yard they had to decide
prior to entering the contour which
woman shall lay with whom as to not
repeat an incident that occurred
previously which presumably was a fight
between two guys over a girl back in
Bergen and another three years have
passed and you have been promoted to the
title of Gessle which in English would
be something like journeyman or junior
partner this basically means you work
directly under one of the Masters also
known as just a merchant in the contour
go with him on sailing expeditions to
business meetings and sometimes you're
even allowed to make your own small
business decisions you gather valuable
knowledge about how the hazard elite
operates what are its rules etc after a
couple of years of this and almost at
the end of your seven to ten years stay
at the Bergen contour you're finally
promoted to the status of a Meister
basically meaning master in German this
means you're finally allowed to make
your own way in life and in the league
you no longer have to work under any
merchants you can conduct your own
business within the league make your own
trade deals and even participate in the
contour and the league elections you can
also run for office as if you want to
like house
the head of a yard the oxen are one of
the 18 councillors of the contour or
older louder one of the three elder men
in the contour if you are very ambitious
you can even become a representative of
the Hanseatic city on the handset tack
the highest Hanseatic office which meets
in Lubich and basically has the final
say in every Hanseatic affair but hold
all those thoughts because you're
technically not done yet
going from a guest cell to a Meister you
have to go through not one not two but
three initiation ceremonies which in
Bregan are known as the Hanseatic games
so let's begin the smoke test the first
initiation ceremony is a spectacle for
the entire city crowds from all over
Bergen gather to witness your hazing
okay I can't do that voice for the
entire time sorry
so the first initiation ceremonies are
spectacle for the entire city crowds
from all over Bergen gather to witness
your hazing the boats in the harbor are
decorated in colorful Flags ornaments
etc also each yard is proudly waving its
own special flag as well senior members
of the contour pass in a procession
through the city followed by the Steuben
unions with buckets the Steuben unions
gather into the buckets all the
filthiest things they can find on the
streets as the procession goes along
sometimes even being held by the locals
who brought their own dirty things to
put into the bucket parade is also
accompanied by gesture masked figures
and two people entertaining the crowd
dressed as the poorest peasants
imaginable oh and you along with other
initiates are there as well
once the procession enters the Guildhall
bryggen you are tied and hauled up into
the chimney after that the Stuben unions
drop all the contents of their buckets
into the fireplace and a fire is started
during this time you're repeatedly
lowered from the chimney and questioned
on various merchants knowledge when the
senior merchants see you are at the
brink of suffocation you are promptly
taken out of the chimney and doused with
six buckets of ice-cold water
congratulations you have passed the
first task
there is a giant banquet healthier and
other initiates honor there is plenty of
drinking eating singing etc however when
the stops you're promptly stripped off
from all of your clothing this is so
that everyone can make sure you are a
male because allegedly one time a woman
was almost a minute to the leaked to
horror once completely naked you're
taking out on a boat into the harbor
where you're thrown into the ice-cold
water every time you try to get back up
into the boat you're beaten back into
the water with a stick keep in mind
while all of this is happening everyone
is quite drunk this continues on for a
couple of minutes until you're brought
back up into the boat and back to the
contour congratulations you have passed
the second task happening on a separate
day than the actual flogging you and
other initiates are required to go on a
procession through the town to the st.
Mary's Church Cemetery where the locals
have already gathered in large numbers
you and other initiates then take turns
and climb on a tree from which you yell
out and minute details every sexual act
you had with every woman whilst at
Bergan apparently the locals found this
very amusing on the day of the last
initiation another procession of the
most senior members of the contour and
drummers go through the town in the
morning to the nearby forest where they
cut the most painfully looking branches
from a tree then they come back to the
contour where they give an address to
all the initiates about the importance
of the leek its community and that you
can still back out if you don't want to
be a member after that another giant
banquet is held at noon with music
singing drinking etc apparently special
care is taken at this time that all the
initiates are very intoxicated by the
time of the flogging then the branches
that have been cut earlier in the day
are given to the most muscular member of
the contour and the initiates are
whipped by them until it's deemed by the
senior members of the contour that's
enough after this the initiates are
given even more alcohol during which if
they pass out they're thrown into the
local well if you survived
congratulations you have passed the
third and last task you're now
officially a full-fledged member of the
Hanseatic League I would also like to
point out that even though very uncommon
some members did die there
these initiation ceremonies but you
don't have to worry about that you
survived and you can now either stay in
the contour and run for an office there
return back to rustic and conduct trade
there or go anywhere else to conduct
business within the Hanseatic League you
can now also finally marry someone and
maybe you found a girl you fancy while
in Bergen so you'll decide to stay who
knows the choice is yours
now before this video ends I want to
emphasize this was just one
representation of a life that a
Hanseatic merchants might have had the
Hanseatic League was a giant medieval
trade guild spanning multiple centuries
their life experiences of a hands-on
merchant in the 13th century differed
widely from the hands of merchants in
the 16th century in the later half of
the league's existence
there were even instances of
german-speaking slavic and baltic people
becoming merchants within the guild plus
even in this small snippet of time in
the early 15th century that I have shown
in this video the experiences of each
merchant in the Hansa were very
different as well
for example the bergen contour was
notorious even within the Hazar for its
hazing clothes of community and unique
administrative structure the London
contour on the other hand was a much
more open-ended community without such
rigidly defined social structures they
were still there just not as harsh in
the Novgorod contour young merchants
were even encouraged to live amongst
Russian farmers so they learned the
language because that would be
beneficial for their trade later on and
many merchants who signed up with the
Hanseatic League didn't even live in a
contour they simply worked with a well
known medieval apprenticeship structure
under a merchant master going from one
hanza city to another Hansa city and
conducting in layman's terms trade they
did this until they reached the stage to
be elevated to a master with in the
hands of themselves after which just
like you becoming a master in the
contour they could conduct trade on
their own anywhere in the Hanseatic
League there are so many variables
within the Hanseatic League that changed
depending on many other variables that
the only way I saw it possible to
present how the Hanseatic League
operated was through showing just one
specific time period in one specific
geographical area otherwise this video
would have had too many asterisks
attached to everything I said hope you
enjoyed the video don't forget I have a
patreon you can support me on and there
more information clarifications and
corrections in the description as always
my name is Emma laser and stick around
for history
[Music]